I saw this book it's called golden days
Jack McCallum he's a Hall of Fame NBA
writer and he he's comparing or at least
trying to bring together the stories of
jerry west lakers of the early 70s Steph
Curry's warriors of today and he says
California dreamers who reinvented
basketball and Jack McCallum kind enough
to join us hi jack how are you today how
are you doing that explained the book
explain what you're comparing with these
two eras and of course Jerry West is the
common thread because he worked with the
Warriors and it was the star of those
Laker teams well it started out as kind
of a a sort of a disposition on winning
streaks that Lakers team that you
mentioned with Jerry and and Wilt
Chamberlain won 33 straight games that
just got into my head that was just an
unbelievable number and while I was
planning the book the Warriors were in
the process of winning you know they
were in the middle of this winning
streak that ended at depending on how
you're counting you know 24 or 27 and
and Jerry at that time was a consultant
for the Warriors and I just saw a chance
to talk about two teams from different
eras through the prism of one guy the
Warriors ended up screwing up my
symmetry because they didn't win the
championship and then they got Kevin
Durant in the offseason so it kind of
became necessary to talk about the
Warriors this season so it turned into
less of a thing about winning streaks
and more of a book about the way two
teams did things the way the Lakers did
it the Warriors did it the comparisons
between them the contrast between them
with Jerry always as the central
character as you know always a
fascinating figure but you say
California dreamers how did they
reinvent basketball how did the Lakers
reinvent basketball you know I can look
at Golden State and understand that now
but what was someone inventive about
what the Lakers were doing
well I think that you know back if you
took back when jack jack kent cooke sort
of invented for the NBA kind of modern
marketing if you will I mean he wouldn't
spend a dime to get a new film projector
but you know he built the fabulous forum
he build his team with stars he had kind
of a different model than the other
owners back then and it ended up of
course you know nobody liked them by the
by the end of it and you know the team
fell apart after that championship
season but I think he was really a
visionary in terms of the way he
constructed a team built the new Arena
built the kind of show you know the
magic that turned into show time and
then turned it over to Jerry Buss who
did sort of the same thing
the modern Warriors doing it kind of
with this Silicon Valley Hollywood
mashup that they have with Joel a cup
and Peter Guber
and you know I think the Warriors are
kind of going forward the duo of the new
paradigm in the NBA but you know you
can't do what they did if you don't have
the players I think at the that's the
final thing that comes out of it if you
don't have good players it doesn't
matter what the heck you deal with with
marketing or putting teams together or
anything else you need two players and
obviously the Warriors have that do the
Warriors know that they border on being
unlikable I think they do I think that
that curry at least you know really
really understands it they you know I
went out there thinking when I when I
researched the book last year I went out
there thinking that the high knucklehead
factor of draymond Green that I would
hear a you know a lot more about that
and within the structure of that team
draymond is is is really important facet
of it and I think they kind of
understand that you know they never
really had that toughness even when they
won the you know in 15 before Durant
got there they sort of on they were sort
of a more lovable team then and then
when they got Kevin Durant you know
they're kind of this this thing started
that they were too powerful and Durant
went ring hunting and you know that's a
whole other dialogue we could have and I
think that this the more intelligent
that the guys that look at the game or
understand that they do have a high
unfavorability index but you know in
sports tennis you know nothing binds a
team more than hey everybody hates us
you know nobody likes us and I think now
they're sort of trying to build on that
a little bit and but it feels like
Durant is bothered by it jack whereas
the other guys may embrace it Durant is
way too sensitive with this it feels
like no no question I mean I said that
in the book I think that he has to Kevin
is in a way as much as he's accomplished
in the league I mean he's been the
league now you know ten years he's a
veteran he's won an MVP award he won a
Finals MVP he still kind of plays this I
don't get no respect
card and he still seems to be a sort of
a project a guy in making not on the
court
I mean he's fantastic but trying to
figure out what he is in the league he's
not as comfortable doing that in a way
as as Steph Curry is I think Steph had
it figured out more than KD and it's
going to be interesting this year their
second year together with this
embarrassment of riches to see how they
handle it the book is called golden days
west Lakers Steph's Warriors and the
California dreamers who reinvented
basketball the owner is Jack McCallum do
you think this is LeBrons last stop
Cleveland oh boy somehow I think not I I
don't have any inside information on
that but I could just see him you know
he has a home in Los Angeles I could
just see him kind of this team this year
which is still very good mainly because
he's on it
is kind of a makeshift type of team it
has it as a feeling of a kind of last
year you know let's get let's get the
band together back for you know do one
more oldies tour and LeBron at the end
of the season is still going to be you
know at the top of his game I just see
him wanting to reinvent himself and a
team one more time and the logical place
you would think it would be would be
with the Clippers or the or the Lakers
but I don't you know I don't know what's
inside the man's soul the only thing I
thought jack is he knows he can't match
Michael Jordan's Finals record but he
can do something that nobody else in the
history of the game is done and that's
lead three different franchises two NBA
titles which makes the argument a little
different as far as greatest player of
all time could could you see that
rationale sure absolutely I think
everybody all these guys always have you
know kind of Michael on their mind and
if LeBron has the idea that you know he
wants to get past Michael and this is
the only way he can do it three
different teams that is kind of that
would be a phenomenal record that might
be in his thinking but you know he that
homecomings it seemed that that when he
went to Cleveland that idea that I'm
coming back this is my past and this is
where I made it big and this is where I
learned the game that's pretty strong
too and my own guess is that LeBron
doesn't have that quite figured out
himself yet I think he you know it's
probably gonna see what happens this
this season if he gets these guys if he
gets these guys to a title that would
that would really be something
particularly you know considering how
the Western Conference was remade in
Houston and Oklahoma City
not to mention Golden State in the
perennial San Antonio Jack great to talk
to you again and good luck with the book
and thanks for joining us all right
thank you Dan that's Jack McCallum NBA
Hall of Fame writer in the book
called golden days for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]